Đó thì có lại yếu cầu các thương nhân từ kện nghiêm các quy định về phối chọn cùng ứng sẵn xin học,
màu đàn của nha phụ vũ nếu cầu tiêu dùng và sẵn xuất,
cuộc yêu cầu các dân nghiệp tịch nối không để gián vận của nguồn cùng sẵn xin học trong par hệ thống.
Từ đầu mối, phần phối đến các gờ hàng mắn lại sẵn dầu,
cho mọi tình muốn tích các đần đi phải bảo đàn của cấp đầy đủ sẵn xin học cho các gờ hàng mắn lại.
Thục hệ thậu của nguồn phối, nhằm duy trì hoạt động và hẵn thường suyên với lý tục.
Hãy bảo vệ phần phối một cách hợp lý để bảo đàn về cuộc ứng sẵn xin học cho thì chân không bị gián vận.
Các dân nghiệp cũng cần bố chỉ nụ như lực tổ chức chực, hóa tăng ca thì cần thiết,
nhằm duy trì hoạt động và hẵn hẵn hẵn đầy đủ. Tóc ở mùi cầu của nguồn gần và dân nghiệp.
Cục còn lý và phát triển tị trường trong lưỡa cuộc yêu cầu các thương nhân đầu mối,
phần phối sẵn dầu theo dõi chặt trẻ dễ dễ biến têu thủ sẵn xin học cho thì chân.
Chơi hợp em phát triển khó khăn bước mắt cận kìt thời bảo gáo để được xem sát và sử li.